peace be with you
assalamualaikum thank you for tuning in
to the Deen show this special episode
we're gonna be talking about the Eid
what is Eid the significance of Eid why
do we practice II what are the some of
the practices during Eid all of this and
there are many innocent children dying
in Gaza and other parts of the world and
now we're having this joyous occasion so
how can we for all those who are being
oppressed also what can we do to help
what can we do to help during these
troubling times all of this and more
with my next guest here on the D show
don't go anywhere we'll be right back
this is the this is the thing
this is the days of the teacher this is
the assalamu alaikum peace be with you
walaikum Salam o Allah he barked at how
I share hamd a lot of Malala me and
thank you for having me thank you for
being under these show Eid inshallah
Donna eat is here now and many people
now we cater to a lot of the not yet
Muslims many of the Muslims now also now
is that time of the year we're going to
be celebrating so people want to know
what are these Muslims celebrating
what's it all about we just getting
through the Ramadan can you talk to us a
little bit about II smell ar-rahman
rahim I it is a term that relates to the
Arabic word from Isaiah wrote something
that keeps coming back and if we go back
to the essence of the presence of
Muslims on earth it's all about acts of
worship tower God so we are in constant
reflecting on how we can keep worshiping
Allah spano Tala and the celebration
that comes after finishing an act of
worshipped our God if you recall the
prophets words Allah Allah Selim that he
mentioned about Friday being the read on
a weekly basis for Muslims and there's
nothing else on that day but the Friday
noon prayers Allah - jimana so for that
act of worship it is something to be
celebrated if we look at the month of
Ramadan we are celebrating after we
finish fasting that we have done our
active worshiped our God and the theme
behind all that we are celebrating the
revelation of the Quran from Allah span
atala to the Prophet SAW solemn and then
to humanity to follow up on that so the
essence behind the celebration of aid is
that even after Hajj for example one
people finish pilgrimage we celebrate
that so we do an act of worship we are
grateful to Allah that he gave us a
chance to reach out to him through ways
that he will be pleased with us and we
celebrate for that now let's back it up
we just finished the Ramadan right so
now is this in line with the tradition
of all the prophets that every prophet
they worship the one creator not the
creation and then the
a stood and then they are we is this
something now this then is new or is
this something a tradition that we were
following this from the original way we
believe that there are four components
that were always the same between all
prophets and messengers that were sent
by God we believe that all prophets and
messengers came to tell people about God
the second thing to worship him alone
the third is to invite people to that
which is of bringing benefit and
preventing harm and number four the line
of ethics and morals so under the line
of worshiping one God we believe it is
something that connects with people and
the major basics if it was prayer overt
was charity or if it was fasting and the
verse in Surat al-baqarah is very clear
bismillah Rovner ahim yeah you have
latina a man who kuta bali como cmk
Makuta bala lady named in kabbalah comme
la lagune taught upon so fasting o you
who believe has been ordained on you the
way it was ordained on people prior to
you now there might be differences and
the way practices are being made from
one generation to another as far as the
messages from the time of the Musa
al-salaam
or to the time of a silence I am to the
time of the Prophet salah salem and
details but the essence the theme is
always there so it is not something new
it is an extension of the same idea of
how to worship and reach out to God and
tell us now what what are some of the
the practices during this Eid from when
you get up in the morning and now
throughout the whole day how many days
is it last for the filter or idle filter
that you are an after Ramadan it is
about a prayer that people should be
ready for of course from the memory of
the day before you start what we call a
tech beer right after when you finish
salat is Maghrib and then after Asia and
then after fajar it is about as Allah
said well he took cap billahil ma
hadouken so you would praise Allah
spanic Allah for that which he guided
you for worshiping him span Adan so
after you finish MRIB you start making
allah ho akbar allahu akbar as a
celebration that you have declared there
is nothing more greater than allah he is
the one to be worshipped and you do this
until the fed of the morning of day it's
different it stays longer and the ID of
Allah it goes with what we call
- react when people are in Mina so it's
extends three more days but for Idol
footer it stops after salat actually
want people when the imam goes to
deliver solid lead and public people in
the morning the first thing they need to
do is just to break the fast actually
this is how you celebrate you finish so
you should not delay breaking your fast
after Fajr like you're not fasting at
that day and then you get yourself ready
for the prayer itself it is meant to be
taken outside the mosque so you can host
as many people the Prophet sallallaahu
limit was narrated that you'd bring
women elderly children everyone is to
come to this joyful joined act of
worship between people people are to
dress well to smell well and make sure
that they are and the best looking for
their Lord to celebrate that and of
course social gathering you have to be
neat and you have to be looking nice the
etiquette is that people sit down and
wait for the prayer making also takbir
and these words of takbir it is the same
declaration of what all this life is all
about we are here to to Kabira lejana
Mahad I come to praise Allah for that
which he guided us for then there will
be the call for the pray there is no
event for it there is no a family Craig
Euler you know time we do for regular
Salah but rather the Imam will take the
lead and he will perform a prayer which
is made of 2 rakaat what's also
different about this prayer it's that
it's filled with takbir - so when you
enter the first takbir which is called
takbir actually Haram that's when you
enter Salah would you follow that by
seven additional tech Bharat Allahu
Akbar Allahu Akbar and you do that seven
times raising your hands every time with
that and then when you stand for the
second record you add another five so
it's all about takbir and praising God
also the hood but at the time of the
read is something that relate to that
which is of the needed issues of the
community to the public so the Imam
after when he is done with the prayer he
will take and deliver a hood bow remind
people of these issues that are
important to them including relating to
other Muslims around the world
especially in these
times that they are having you know
hardships around the world and this is
the time that we see significant number
of Muslims coming and attending the
hotbar of a solid lead
so the message should be universal the
message should be inviting people to
practice Islam and hopefully that will
be a reason for them to commit later on
so that's interesting the tech beer is
what how would you define tech beer this
work it is Allahu Akbar god is great
it's a declaration that nothing is
greater than God and that should lead
you into understanding that life is to
be all and total surrender and
submitting to him did Jesus peace be
upon him who we love and revere is one
of the mightiest messengers did he make
this declaration god is great and
greater than anything indeed we believe
that is the standard for all prophets
and messenger all of them yes including
the last in front of us and they thank
you thank you we're gonna take a break
and we right back with more here on the
Deen show celebrating Eid we'll be right
back bismillah alhamdulillah Salaam
alaikum peace be with you distill I
humbly like Salam alaikum peace be unto
you Allah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
bismillah alhamdulillah Salam aleikum
peace be unto you welcome to the Deen
show bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you greetings of
peace to everybody all around the globe
that's tuning in to the Deen shop back
here on the Dean show of our special
guests we're talking about Eid now let's
back it up a little bit fasting is
finished we're getting done with that
you get a lot of momentum you get really
motivated during Ramadan so we don't
want this to fizzle away how can we keep
the momentum going for all year round
well Ramadan is meant to be more like a
faith station that it should give you
the dose you start by the relativity to
the hadith of the Prophet saws a lambda2
ever fast Ramadan and followed it by six
of showa so the fasting should not
vanish from your daily encounters and
then it is match to be you know the
whole year as if it's being fast because
if you multiply things by 10 times 30
times then that's 300 and then six times
then that's sixty so total of 360 which
is between the lunar calendar that's
where it is so you keep all the diverse
ways of engaging I bed and
worship to God even if it was in fasting
and then after that even you know the
nebula or the additional things that are
too fast mondays or Thursday
but if Ramadan is meant to celebrate the
revelation of the Quran through fasting
which gives you a chance to rise in your
spiritual relationship with God honoring
the revelation of the Quran this should
reflect on a peace that comes within
your heart and that's where it is
mentioned to be in lailatul Qatar which
we celebrated hamdullah sterday at the
end of the verse in Surat al-hadid says
Salam when he had time applying fetch so
this piece that you are able to enjoy
and feel throughout the month of Ramadan
peaked at the night of al-qaeda or the
decree should give you this tranquility
that should go along with you throughout
the whole year till next year in
charlotte ala and this is the
relationship where you combine
submitting to god surrendering to them
and having peace which both are and the
title of islam itself to submit and then
you fight peace and that so it should
reflect and attract quality inside and
that peace within yourself should
reflect on the way you conduct yourself
with allah a relationship within your
own self and with people around you
someone says look I caught the month two
twenty around the 27th and I'm banking
on the thousand you know the months
better than then you know so I'm getting
all my worshiping on this month and then
they go back to maybe to the bar to the
nightclub and they Bank on this one
night it is a matter of how can utilize
acts of worship to make difference as
Allah said some lot of maraheim in NASA
let attend hand in fashion evil moon car
Salah should prevent people from
engaging that which is a fashio you know
filthiness of Acts and in social you
know diseases al-munkar that's which is
evil so we hope that people if they are
sincere when they come into Ramadan and
we invite everyone regardless what their
background to come experience this
pleasure of connecting with allah and it
will cash back into positive approach
toward a better act of worship in
general no one is immune from falling
into sins but let it be known that the
Prophet told
selasa Lanois hiya hatta in Etowah boon
the best among those who commit sins
that they repent to Allah span at all
the doors of repentance are open and let
everyone make of Ramadhan a phase that
will give him better strength to believe
in himself that he can do better and
inshallah change his lifetime lifestyle
to that which pleases Allah span Adana
so you mentioned this Salah this is that
connection five times a day in sincerity
in it this should be enough now if
you're sincere in it this will ward off
you know you going back to any bad
things that you're doing evil things and
if your heart is connected to the
hereafter then you probably won't want
to be in places that it is pleasing to
your Creator right it goes both ways
there is something that you have to let
go those evil things so you can enjoy
the beauty of the good things it goes
both way but we say if someone is let us
say you know engaging some bad things we
believe that if we invest in good things
all types of good you know acts of
worship if it was prayer if it was
charity if it was fasting you know the
nun obligated you know nebula it builds
a mountain of hasanat that will go
against the mountain of Siot or bad
deeds that he had and Allah said and the
Quran in al hasanat used him Ness AF
that the good deeds wash away the bad
deeds and there's a scale at the door
judgment more good deeds versus bad
deeds so more goodies you will go to
heaven plus you are going to enjoy the
sweetness of these acts of worship and
hopefully in Charlotte will be a reason
for you to let go these bad deeds how
can we balance it out now Eid is
supposed to be a very joyous occasion
and we're supposed to be celebrating but
we see innocent children being killed
massacred you know women also and in in
the mix of all this and now it brings
tears to your eyes your heart breaks so
how do you balance this out mash it the
way that we are watching now what's
happening if it was a Naza if it was in
Syria and other parts of the world your
heart is torn and to pieces
seeing these children who are supposed
to be having new clothes on the day of
aid having some candy visiting family
members but yet they are being buried
without even access to cemeteries
without even access to safety through
during the burial itself
funerals are being bombarded people when
they are trying to seek shelter on the
streets they are being bombarded and
this is something that is very tough and
hard to process but we believe that
inshallah the people who are going
through these hardships that they find
and the concept of worship behind it
that's the beauty of giving them subber
and patience to cope destiny will roll
the cutter of Allah will never change
but faith helps you cope with that and
trial on we're going to get back with
more on this topic and the Eid and how
you can make dua and what you can do to
help those who are suffering or being
oppressed the innocent men women and
children all over the world we right
back with more here on the Deen show I
am not afraid to stand I am not afraid
to stand alone if Allah is by my side I
am not afraid to stand alone I am not
afraid to stand alone if Allah is I am
not afraid
I am Not Afraid to stand alone if Allah
is by my side
I am Not Afraid to stand
back here on the Dean show
shake now you being a community leader
you deal with a lot of different people
from different cultures backgrounds
religions and you know very well a lot
of the negative stereotypes that are
associated with Islam so what do you say
when some people try to make Islam out
to be like the boogeyman that Islam is
against a certain people certain rays
you know and it's against peace my
advice to all those people you know
after 9/11 we have seen a huge
difference in the numbers of non-muslims
attending the mosque actually learning
about Islam for example we have lot of
students that come from all kind of
universities around us in Chicago and
now Islam is number one pick for their
world religion or comparative religion
or even churches bringing you know
congregants or high schools or even
middle schools bringing students we
always leave them with one piece of
advice ignorance is dining the the more
that you distance yourself from the
truth from the people themselves and you
rely on propaganda from other people
then you are inviting ignorant to decay
that which is in your conscious about
other people so as the first revelation
that was revealed on the Prophet said
read Achra we are asking people around
us to read about us from us from our
sources from the Quran and the Sunnah
and hopefully that will change their
perspective about what Islam is all
about so tell us board let's go back to
a weird timer before you we went to
break break we mentioned we have
innocent kids and the you know that are
losing their future you know the the
death rate is in the hundreds and these
innocent kids anyone who has a daughter
or a son and they see some of these
images is just heartbreaking and and
even the ones that are injured many of
them you know they'll probably never be
the same again so what can we do now to
help and their that's their struggle for
their freedom for their equality for the
right to live for not to be under siege
but from our side we have a liability as
the prophet mentioned Salalah holly
salem al muslim a whole muslim that the
Muslim is the brother from you you owe
him certain liabilities of standing next
to him so it is my duty to start by
feeling with him
and then remembering him and my special
prayers and the power of dois is great
but then it needs to also make sure that
if there's an orphan I want to make sure
that he has food to eat if there is
someone with injury that he needs you
know the medicine if it was the
antibiotic or if it was the anesthesia
people are being operated on in Syria
NASA without anesthesia because of siege
and lack of access to them so donations
that might bring these and hamdullah we
are blessed with many relief agencies
that are working with international
other agencies to bring these you know
aid to these people so that which you
can if it was writing an article in a
newspaper to speak the truth if you are
to take a demonstration and you know
raise a flag of freedom and equality
everything counts and this has come in
to your role and responsibility and you
are not asked to be seen and judge on
the outcome you are asked on your effort
have you done your homework and
alhamdulillah we have many venues that
we can do that in challenge what are the
other advice do you give us to all those
people who are tuning in from all over
the globe for this joyous occasion of
Eid well it is a moment to celebrate
arribada and we celebrate a better by
continuing the ibeda itself so it is not
something that ramadan is finished so
i'm gonna stop coming to the masjid
ramadan is finished i'm not going to
wake up for Fajr anymore and go to the
mosque if you did it in Ramadan that
means that you are able to do it in
shallow ramadan is meant to help you
train yourself into new habits that will
get you closer to allah the fasting is
not meant to stop only from food or
drink the fasting trained you to stop
your eyes from looking at harm your
either at listening to haram your legs
taking you to an haram and if you are
able to do that during Ramadan and
Charlotte will be with you after Ramadan
real quick before we depart is it true
that some of the people who are tested
the most were the prophets and then
those closest to them and does that mean
now that God Almighty loves
he's testing you how can we take when
people are going through trials and
tribulations how should we look at this
it is mentioned very clearly in the
hadith of the Prophet Salla Salam is a
beloved than if they live Allah loves
someone he will test him why because if
Allah knows there's a certain level for
you in heaven an honorable one and your
own deeds are not helping you reach that
and Allah loves you he will bring these
tests and trials to you so you would be
able to relate to that with patience and
being more close to Allah your prayers
will be different you're doing your the
way you pray and concentrate and
practice kosher and that will make you
closer to Allah even the worship of the
heart you know the way you relate to
Allah spanha Thailand your heart so the
good Allah does not create something
hundred percent evil it is about things
that will be seen in the outcome and if
the outcome is heaven alhamdulillah for
all the tests and the trials Angela so
is your Masjid now where you're at your
mosque is it open to any person who
wants to come in and learn about Islam
is Islam exclusive just to a certain
people is it for everybody being here
Christian a Jew a Hindu is are your
doors open to anyone who wants to come
in mass foundation.org and then they can
call us at any time if it was an
individual if it was a group if it was a
church if it was a synagogue of it was a
temple if it was students
everyone is welcome we have beautiful
presentations to give about Islam let
people come and learn from the Muslims
themselves
thank you so much Mary Allah the Creator
the heavens and earth bless your Eid is
a collection for you - and your family -
thank you so much and thank you for
tuning into the Deen show Eid you got to
know the significance of it the
practices do it and now as the last and
final messenger sent to mankind upon
Muhammad peace be upon me said Atari
booming and them becoming them Bela the
one who repents from sin is like the one
who has no said you've been repenting to
the crater alone this whole month and
now you've gotten a momentum don't let
it slow down continue to do good
continue to develop yourself to be the
best human being possible you've used
this month of Ramadan as a catalyst now
to take off with it
don't let it slow down continue to be
good continue to work for the Hereafter
by doing good deeds by developing
yourself to be the best
that's right and don't slow down and
continue to make du'a continue continue
to make dua for all those suffering and
oppressed innocent men women and
children out there and before you ever
complain think about those who have less
and wish to have what you have and we'll
see you next time follow us on the
Facebook join us and keep up with our
show support the Deen show we'll see you
next time God will until that peace be
with you